gilles tu es d'accord à que booba oui
parce qu'ils refusaient pris en otage je
le dis c'est pas lui oui il est bien sûr
il est contre la guerre bat en ukraine
voilà là c'est un peu c'est un cri de
liberté absolument me voilà c'est un
homme libre qui ne veut pas être
instrumentalisée par une marque qui n'a
rien demandé la signent un contrat
commercial on veut l'entraîner sur un
terrain si on lui avait demandé son avis
de leur est donné mais là je trouve que
on l'obligé à faire quelque chose et la
rupture pour moi c'est courageux parce
qu'il se prive d'un contrat ça reste un
homme libre qu'on soit d'accord avec lui
ou pas oui quand même c'est ça et ça
s'arrache fond c'est ça c'est ça c'est
ça c'était du jamais vu je suis désolé
c'est quelqu'un qui les gens qui sont
pas d'accord et plus complètement voilà
je comprends qu'il y ait plein qui sont
acquis et se sont insurgés voilà son riz
mais en fait c'est pas une décision
politique non c'est une décision en fait
voilà que celle ci n'est que puma mais
après donc ça veut dire que tous les
gens qui ont des contrats avec des
marques qui sont peu russie vont arrêter
ces contrats il ne fait aucune
compromission avec la liberté après
chacun se déterminera mais lui et moi
j'aime bien que c'est dresser des
milliers d'euros sur lesquels ils
pourraient voilà je pense un parce que
je pense qu'il ya un gros contrat avec
plus d'un million même dans la vie et la
santé 2020 il l'avait pris alors qu'il
était incroyable convoité c'est
incroyable donc moi je trouve très
courageux de sa part de renoncer à
dégâts énormes au nom de sa liberté
d'expression ne transige pas avec sa
liberté et pour ça je trouve que booba
raison je suis d'accord kelly bah moi je
pense que c'est le contraire d'autres on
peut lancer la position elle peut être
aussi humaine on peut se dire pas
pourquoi tu enlève tous les magasins en
russie est ce que le peuple il a décidé
de faire la guerre en irak le président
qui a décidé dans la guerre y'a pas le
peuple donc en fait il ya combien de
personnes qui vont être au chômage ya
combien de personnes qui vont se
retrouver à pouvoir vivre pourquoi pas
ce que sont leurs présidents êtes un
taré à kaka connaissant notre peuple
donc moi je suis pour aussi me dire que
bah en fait il ya des positions à
prendre et d'autres non couper les
vivres aux olives aux oligarques en
france en europe dans le monde entier
oui pourquoi pas mais couper les vivres
au peuple non je suis pas d'accord
daniel qui dit non voilées alors je
trouve très courageux ça c'est vrai mais
je moi excusez moi je ne savais pas par
exemple que booba avait un contrat avec
avec puma et je trouve malsain ainsi cet
acte avait décompté implicitement on a
l'impression qu'il soutient qui se
souvient quand même poutine je sais bien
que c'est paris - non mais je sais bien
que c'est pas ça mais quand on connaît
rien à rien excusez moi mais ce qu'est
ce qu'il en reste et là je trouve qu'il
a tort parce qu'en ce moment il faut
vraiment à tous solidaires je sais que
l'attention dès que sa mauvaise -
jean-louis s'il avec ses idées s'il a
décidé comme il a dit vous décidez de
vous engager sur la guerre moi j'ai pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas signer avec vous pour
ça il décide d'arrêter comme vous avez
dit c'est courageux maintenant peut-être
elle nous courageux tête que courageuse
et un verre mais pour ac les
compressions
peut-être que maintenant puma je pense
que puma n'a pas besoin de booba pour
vivre et je pense que peut-être que puma
va lui demander des sous maintenant on
échange parce que si la casse a un
contrat et qui n'aura bougé des sous en
avance peut-être qu'à part qu'ils
rendent l'argent en tout cas ce serait
mon kiki dans chacun de leur côté
bernard montiel faire ce qu'il veut non
moi je trouve courageux les grandes
enseignes qui se retire ou en tout cas
qui ferment leurs magasins comme le
groupe lvmh d'ailleurs il ferme tout et
dieu sait que c'était un gros marché
parce que les russes là en tout cas les
russes qui ont du fric qu'ils achètent
chez vite on chez dior et tout ça ils
ont fermé tous leurs magasins
c'est en revanche je termine il ya là
d'autres qui restent là-bas comme la
famille mulliez fait les casinos les
auchan les tout ça et eux ils restent
ouverts bon ça peut poser à la flexion
maintenant chacun fait comme il veut
mais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant de
prendre position quand même contre
poutine qui est quand même un agresseur
qui fait peur à tout le monde benjamin
oui aussi oui parce que bah oui parce
que la vérité c'est qu'on fait pas de la
guerre au peuple russe fait ça bien sûr
c'est ça la vraie réponse donc je peux
comprendre après c'est vrai qu'il ya le
risque pour lui c'est qu'on le met du
côté de poutine je préfère que ce soit
le cas du tout et preuve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le peuple russe souffre
évidemment de toutes les sanctions et
pour l'instant les oligarques ils ont
perdu quoi un iota gosse a un truc à
droite mais rien de très important et le
peuple est souhaitée puis de tout est
absolument de tout ces voiliers du radis
n'apprendra guillaud ben moi parler de
courage sauf que c'est obscène en fait
moi je trouve que c'est pas du tout le
buzz c'est pas du tout le duc je trouve
que c'est juste un pleutre qui à miami
qui nous donne des leçons dont je trouve
que c'est dégueulasse parce que
aujourd'hui on est en guerre et on est
soit avec soit contrée ya pas tergiversé
à tordre de comme ça et pardon mais
booba toujours fait de la politique tout
ce qu'il fait et géraldine il ne donne
aucune chance c'est limite mais lisez
son communiqué je vais je n'ai pas signé
pour ça ni aucune leçon non mais booba
ne fait que de la politique mais il
vient ici ebuzz messia il fait de la
leur mais la météo mais il fait que de
la politique qui disent pas que quand il
paraît que vous vous n'en faites pas oui
gymnique géré a déjà joué j'étais nommé
mois si vous nous en donner tout laisse
tous les jours mais oui mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que je nous en donner
tous les jours des leçons de morale et
des leçons de tarifs et de taxes à vous
nous avez fait mais peuvent commencer à
payer pour sauver les body soul son ouïe
la médina mais sauf que la nuit se
trouve que vous n'arrêtez monopole de la
bonne conscience humaine et mondiale
géraldine tesson et bâillonné quand on
n'est pas bonne route malaisie mais bon
ça fait deux heures ou par les non
j'imagine valeurs communes interrompu
par chirac sans vous avez parlé tous les
jours alors allez-y terminé en quoi
c'est un problème de paris saclay non
mais c'est pas ça c'est que les dossiers
on sait que vous avez eu du changement
la venue chez vous at elle donné aux
autres son analyse il finissait je
venais dire merci parce qu en vue de
savoir que c'est indigne et c'est
dégueulasse et qu'il est du côté des
collabos en disant ça et c'est
dégueulasse voilà salut toi même tu veux
pas dire non mais laissez la fille
délicate pour les pinots maintenant
quels sont les pays qui ne veulent pas
les sanctions pour la russie aujourd'hui
ja je connais tu es là la syrie et trois
dictatures voilà et donc booba et de ce
côté là excuse moi il ya un problème il
faut être un peu plus un peu plus subtil
que ça compte alors qu
il ne prend aucunement partie dans le
conflit lui c'est un art en disant ça
mais nous avons un style est là pour
divertir les gens ici qui dit rachète il
buzze messias qui me va faire de
politique justement il faut travailler
que depuis leurs années dix caméras
dites donc vous laissez pas parler les
jambes il veut exercer un léger
voile il ne fait pas de politique et je
me mets à sa place il a signé un deal
avec une marque ya quelques années
aujourd'hui cette marque prend parti
dans un conflit géopolitique alors
qu'elle ne l'a jamais fait auparavant ça
lui pose problème il se sent utiliser et
donc d'où cette petite phrase on n'a pas
signé pour ça pour moi il a totalement
raison n'a pas signé pour ça géraldine
c'est ça veut dire quoi j'ai pas mal
pour moi booba fait tout le temps de la
politique donc je sais pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous jouez les offusqués en
dix ans booba ne fait jamais de
politique il ne fait que de la politique
vous allez loin quand vous parlez de
collabos en titre in china bedjaoui
importe quoi oui conti tweets sur
charlie hebdo il fait de la politique
quand il parle qu harry harry roselmack
c'est un traître sur villers le bel
oui mais c'est très bien roulé droit de
donner son agrément citoyen engagé
comment et où la droite de donner notre
avis ou géraldine il n'appartient à
personne
voilà il dit genappe je n'ai pas mais
laissez-moi parlé une seconde j'ai ravi
parce que là on est fondée ou pas mais
ça fait dix minutes que vous vous
asseyez de grandes leçons de vie de
maladroits à la droite de thomas 12
entre la droite génial non mais on peut
leur résistance à miami la droite de la
droite de rémy ne résiste à personne il
dit il dit je n'ai pas signé pour ça
vous rompez joron québec le nom de nancy
il dit je ne veux pas travailler avec
une marque qui me prend en otage et qui
portent atteinte à ma liberté c'est un
homme libre qui parler vous le comprenez
à l'envers il ne veut pas être assimilé
à quoi que ce soit il dit moi je fais là
bas il n'est pas d'accord il a certes
fragile mais jean quand tu donnes élèves
à lire être assimilé à qui que ce soit
comme disait que comme disait daniel en
sous texte parfois on comprend pas c'est
à dire qu'on on imagine qu'en disant ça
et il soutient poutine c'est vrai que
dans dix ans je ne soutiens pas les
mesures de rétorsion ça veut dire que du
coup je suis du côté là vous avez été
faussement
une religion qu'est ce que vous répondez
à géraldine quant à valérie peut pas ou
est ce qu'on lit je soutiens poutine ou
est-ce qu'il ya quelle forme de soutien
envers poutine ya dans son tweet aucune
il n'est pas solidaire de puma qui ferme
ses magasins mais quel rapport est ce
que fermer ses magasins la sélection et
connaissent que fermer ses magasins de
faire des sanctions économiques mais est
ce que n'ont pas vraiment besoin de
faire ses sommets la poutine à l'heure
avec
la facture des mecs là puma et oui c'est
pas un acteur un acte assez
nettement pour le coup c'est pas ça veut
pas ça veut laisser finir les gens là là
pour le couple fait qu'il aime ses septs
et des diesels voilà c'est à mon avis de
ses passions ça qu'il faut se battre
maîtrise et et c'est pas un abus
résistance de sa part je te la corde
mais en revanche il a droit de dire je
ne suis pas mort on fait peser un
magasin alors c'est un une censure
contre le peuple raymond quand autant
géraldine et valérie question qui tue
que tu pourrais leur
surgira dîner valérie qui s'en séparent
c'est son choix c'est son choix abou
bassir baissier comme il a signé un
contrat avec puma et là il voit que puma
et avec la russie si lui veut pas
rentrer dans un conflit politique quand
il dit moi je veux pas rentrer là dedans
je veux tu je veux plus avec avec la
nuque rennais la russie je veux plus te
règle avec puma c'est son choix c'est
pour ça que j'ai mis oui c'est son choix
il se démerde son procès vrai qu'on
situe mal attaque derrière qui moi moi
j'ai eu millions on est on a le droit
d'être d'accord ou pas d'accord avec
booba moi je suis complètement comprends
tout à fait les gens ne sont pas
d'accord mais on n'en peut plus des
donneurs de leçons surtout nelson mine
mais il donne pas des leçons il donne
son avis nous bah non avouée par son
avis c'est pas une leçon et pourquoi moi
mais c'est pas non parce que vous allez
dans le sens toujours deux dans le sens
tu vois là dans le sens des donneurs de
leçons anti-poutine la loi et non pas du
tout mais non c'est poutine on est tous
trois étant tiputini s'il allait les
pentes il s'appelle aussi mais pas lui
la section gym et pente il sèche à lui
en disant ça tout le monde et tout le
monde et
ne sais pas qu'est ce que vous voulez
aller lui s'il avait ou non je le
connais pas c'est pas un intime l'avait
eue non je le connais pas ces panneaux
seront là non mais c'est vrai y créer
une handicapée et parce que c'est vrai
oui mais c'est pas ça laissons poutine
de côté tout le monde est maintenant on
va laisser de côté puisque c'est le
sujet mais ça rien à voir c'est sûr mais
les sujets on n'aime pas ses côtés je
n'aime pas ses côtés d'honneur et ça en
fait qui s'était son avis il est
intéressant parce qu'ils divergent de
tout ce qu'on entend en ce moment on a
l'impression qu'on veut sanctionner la
terre entière qu'on veut fermer les
magasins qu'on va interdire attention
divertissante fixé c'est réellement ce à
soutenir l'ukraine s'est pénalisé la
terre entière les les russes les russes
qui veulent aller dans les magasins où
ils peuvent plus y aller maison et jean
berthe et les juges décident de finir by
laurent caure mois donc quoi c'est
simple on va tomber tous ont le même
niveau il s'agit tout mélanger tous les
chaises de la terrasse ou mélanger un
peu touche là c'est un problème que vous
avez gilles et géraldine et et valérie
qui sont au demeurant des femmes
remarquables c'est vrai mais s'envole de
l'endoctrinement total c'est à dire que
vous vous êtes dans une logique g et
tout ce qui sort de votre main
j'ai même pas droit de dire un mot ce
boom interrompue ça c'est vous avez vous
été désarmé à vos cils mais en fait
c'est votre technique à vous deux c'est
d'interrompre les gens
écoutent la voix demande à l'aise et
valeria parce qu'on a eu un loupé
quelque chose que ça devient une vérité
tu attention aux mots que tu utilises
qui parle de cours à radio vous étiez
formidable et dans d'autres aliments je
regrette en bâtiment hier la douma en
russie a voté une loi qui disait que
tout ce qui n'était pas une parole et
validé par le kremlin était passible de
15 ans de prison et bien sûr dans
d'autres et là vous faites de la
politique vous bas vous mélangez wii ou
excuser ces profs d'histoire la chose à
dormez vous mélangez tout le cas mais
moi je voi à 47,4 50 de réussite c'est
assez serré voilà mais c'est vrai que
voilà vous voulez rajouter quelque chose
aux origines non mais
c'est que c'est un peu comme pour le
commune en fait depuis le début de ce
conflit évidemment les images sont
terribles on ne peut que soutenir le
peuple ukrainien mais les médias nous
disent voilà maintenant faut soutenir
l'ukraine faut bannir tout ce qui vient
de russie en allant jusqu'aux magasins
puma qui vendent des shorts donc pardon
le rapport il est parfaitement évident
est ce que dit bouba c'est qui dit qu'à
certains pays notamment par les pays du
golfe qui sont neutres dans ce conflit
et être neutres ce n'est pas soutenir la
russie il ya des raccourcis qui sont qui
ceux qui sont pas évidentes être neutres
ce n'est pas soutenir la russie donc je
pense qu'on peut aussi prendre un peu
plus de recul et ne pas se mettre à
bannir tout et n'importe quoi tu vois
pas en quoi bannir les magasins puma
c'est soutenir l'ukraine je suis désolé
j'ai eu à dire parce qu'en fait je suis
absolument mais ça c'est parce que tu
balances en fait je trouve qu'en fait on
aujourd'hui on est en guerre et on est
soit avec qui on est et on soit contre
et on peut pas tergiverser on est en
guerre déjà on a dit qu'on était en
guerre finalement on n'est pas en guerre
c'est très cd sujet très délicat on me
dit que la france était en guerre
finalement la france et pas en guerre
avec
eux d'ailleurs leur gardien le président
de la république a dit que la france
n'était pas là on est là longtemps mais
ben may à un accord et ont agressé il ya
un prix qui agresse un autre pays furent
non bien sûr mais ce n'est pas parce
qu'on soutient c'est pas parce qu'on
soutient une population qui est
actuellement victime d'une guerre qu'il
faut se mettre à condamner tout ce qui
vient de russie lit pas secrètement
est-ce que c'est des bêtes des symboles
sa pelle à neige c'est pas ça passe ça
personne est quelqu'un qui me dit mon
fils dit que géraldine dit n'importe
quoi il a des amis en russie ils ont
accès à tout un stade etc ils savent ce
qui se passe en ukraine et en tout cas
ils sont contents de manifester pour
dire qu'ils sont opposés au régime de
poutine et son content d'elle sur les
plateaux vous pensez que les citoyens
engagés en russie qui s'appelle oleg
oleg et qui disent qu'on n'ira pas même
aujourd'hui non mais soyez sérieux
mais là
à l'airé géraldine excusez moi mais vous
dépassez les bornes
c'est lui qui met ça
c'est à dire que tout à l'heure des
flics benhaim je ne peux encore mois par
les
rebelles alors laissez nous partir alors
merci géraldine
c'est valérie jazzdor c'est serré c'est
à dire que là vous prêtez à booba des
intentions vous dit carrément en
chicane est d'une bêtise mais papa mais
chez moi
[Rires]
si nous devions foule
[Applaudissements]
ils ont bu bas il a sa singularité et là
vous êtes en train de lui faire un
procès d'intention
en dix ans on est pour on est content
donc de le faire passer vous ai dit
collabos bientôt ce sera un trade mais
arrêter quoi il a dit je suis beau balle
je suis libre je rends mon contrat et là
vous faites un débat autour de ce que
booba pourrait représenter comme
convictions politiques excusez moi vous
délirez vous délirez et booba époux bas
vous n'avez pas instrumentaliser menaï
vous n'avez pas
je ne laisserai pas faire ça moi c'est
toi payet c'est pareil aussi
jamais mais c'est pas les médailles et
les rapports qu'est ce que vous racontez
la mangue et on comprend rien fait mais
ça ne me dit pas c'est aussi de l'ordre
du religieux la psalmodie
champion nabo gonnet parle on est en
train de t'expliquer après tu es libre à
toi de d'être d'accord ou pas d'accord
mais ça s'appelle une conversation donc
c'est pas parce que tu hausse la voix
que je vais mieux entendre donc je leur
dis là c'est tout simplement ce qu'on
ressent quand c'est que soit je les
reçois booba fait du buzz sur le dos des
ukrainiens et c'est pas très joli soit
booba et 2dfacto de parts par son action
il encourage poutine parce que c'est là
où tu fait du buzz sur le réseau
craignent alors est ce que vous
comprenez ces deux possibilités qui
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune des
possibilités c'est juste qu'il a signé
un contrat c'est d'ailleurs ce qui dit
on n'a pas signé pour ça il a signé un
contrat avec une marque pour prêter son
image
aujourd'hui cette marque se positionne
de manière très fort dans un conflit
géopolitique et booba n'a pas envie
d'être assimilée à celle gaza il rompt
son contrat point barre voilà si on aura
l'occasion